all right now what I do after I get in
terms of one variable well the reason
why I got in terms of one variable this
so I can differentiate right now let's
be careful right based on whatever
letters you pick okay I'm
differentiating this guy this is a
function of different shampoo Saudi and
and differentiating with respect to I we
used to seeing exit over here right but
doesn't matter it's just a label okay so
this is the end on dy differentiating
this whole thing with respect to Y ok
there's a nice easy function what's the
derivative yeah minus 16 and the
constant just vanishes okay so great I'm
differentiator what was the point of
getting the derivative okay so I want to
make this equal to 0 so i can find
possible tiny ones yeah by the way
please let's skip the next line namely
this one might be okay don't skip that
even though you know the arithmetic is
really really simple because this shows
that you understand what this is about
okay so therefore from here you can say
why it's for okay hmm all right what do
I do with this this is this is a value
where I'm going to get the turning point
hopefully where do I go next yeah ok so
I could take my quiz for and I could
snap it into Mickey mint oh yeah okay I
guess I've in a diff here that'll give
me value for x right and then what is
the smallest possible value for n I can
pop it into here and then I'll get my
answer which was the two okay but you do
a little bit of work before I actually
substitute it in right I've got to prove
that this is where the smallest bottle
both comes from right which is where all
of this business starts coming you okay
so what should be my next step for
starters it's a turning point well we
think it's a turning point how do we
know if it's a total volume
okay I got it I got a couple options
here we have three options if you
include graphing looks a bit excessive
to me I could use a first video or i can
use a second derivative okay I could
test this guy on either side of the
stationary points second test three and
five or I could use the second
derivative which do you guys reckon we
should go from secondary booth because
it's super easy to differential so
here's the second area right I probably
should have popped in the middle here
determine nature so it's clear why I'm
doing the next derivative ok now it's a
concert right that means every single
stationary point that I fired or which
is really one they should all be concave
ah right this is positive concave up and
concave up meat it's a relative minimum
right now don't skip I can't say it is
the minimum yet well you know how I said
it
as opposed to what I ok because relative
means you know you can have as many
relative minimum as you like you know
what sir is only one we always then I'm
going to go to the Mexican turns can get
you start it's sort of like innocent
until proven guilty right so I know it's
a minimum of some kind but I just don't
have enough evidence to show that it's
sorry coach assess the only ones no not
enough cuz I'm gonna have to get into
endpoints it is a small right where it
couldn't be relative and then turning to
absolute could it be relative if we then
turn into out of the work after why
improvements I don't yet again
everything that's the whole point
relative so pumpkin channels relative
absolute contemporaneous speak yes it
can yes it can what is relative mean
relative means on this contact right
stay with me he's got a point relative
means with respect to like what's nearby
okay so it means minimum relative to
what's in the neighborhood okay nearly
like these few points either side oh
okay the relative minimum is also well
in this case they go Ed's the graph
that's right hit da da hah its relative
minimum as in in the neighborhood it's
the minimal right but it's also it's
also the absolute minimum because
there's no other value that's lower than
because I fixed up my graph ok so yes
relative absolute because where you were
using the word relative and absolute in
very specific ways but you know the test
paper when they asked you to
if it's relative and absolute it's not
all tech boys are absolutely it's always
gonna be relative shopping right that's
that's shirt by the exit it's a tiny
point yeah all right